hi I'm Evan Carmichael and welcome to
another edition of ask Evan
in today's pillow I'm going to ask a
question from one of my readers Richard
who's trying to build an online business
with commission only salespeople he is
trying to go from 1 to 10 people right
now and roll out across North America
hoping that I'll climb right into a
thousand commission only sales people
working for him and he's wondering my
advice on how to build up this
organization so Richard a couple things
for you first up it can be hard to build
a commission only sales person type of
model when you're first starting up
that's kind of the dream of every
entrepreneur because there's no cost you
going down you only pay me when you're
making money but it's hard for sales
people to want to come on because
there's no track record of success so
the best way that you can build it up is
to start by showing that hey this works
and it can generate sales who can make
an income from selling your product or
service that first person might be you
out there hitting the pavement so you
can demonstrate that it works or you
might have to go and get your first
salesperson and pay a base salary or
base you know draw to make sure that
they're able to support themselves while
they kind of build up that process it's
gonna be a lot of mistakes that you guys
will make together as you first start
building this up so you want to make
sure you improve the case with one
person and that first person might not
only be commissioning only sales person
so something to think about
once you feel to build beyond that first
person and you can show that hey this
works I would start building a profile
of what a typical sales person few would
look like so think about the age range
think about male-female think about what
groups and clubs they would belong to
all those types of things that would
kind of create a target profile for an
ideal salesperson for you and then start
hanging up where they're hanging out
Sarah marketing to them start showing
them about the opportunity and the more
you can connect with those people the
greater the chances are that you
the attraction with them to become good
sales people if you want to build an
organization that large you know if
you're talking 500,000 sales people I'd
also look at ways to encourage people
who do join to refer their friends
family colleagues to want to join as
well a great way to find new employees
for business is look at your existing
employee base and see if they know
anybody who might be able to help out if
the seals who have done a good job when
they be able to generate sales then it's
gonna be easy for them to convince their
friends to want to join as well right at
the fit the right demographic the last
thing I would think about is also try to
provide marketing support for them so
they'll just expect them to go up picked
up a phone book and start reaching out
to people see as much as possible them
if you can provide some marketing
support so if you have your website if
you're doing any advertising think about
ways you can help them generate leads to
make it easy for them especially in the
first few months when they might be
excited but it's hard to generate those
first initial leads for the momentum
starts building it think boys you might
be able to support them if they can see
that then it's going to be a lot easier
for you to be able to sign people up to
on enjoy and the organization does the
risk has been drop a little bit because
you're providing these for them so I
hope that helps and have a lot of
information in a couple minutes if you
guys like this video please give it a
thumbs up below
I'd also love to hear your thoughts and
feedback if you want to leave a comment
under the video and stay tuned for next
episode
you